[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este muy breve
especial de cultura en france24 dedicado
a uno de los eventos cinematográficos y
culturales más importantes de todo el
mundo estamos hablando del festival de
cine de cannes el clamoroso festival
francés fue cancelado hace un año debido
por supuesto a la pandemia de
coronavirus y regresa hoy con 24
películas en competición y con un jurado
compuesto mayoritariamente por mujeres y
liderado por primera vez por un director
afro estamos hablando de el
estadounidense spike lee y saludamos ya
mismo a erika olavarría enviada especial
de france 24 que se encuentra presente
en este festival que tiene las miradas
de todo el mundo puestas sobre él
erika da muy buenos días buenas tardes
por allí bueno transmitirte primero un
poco de envidia no estás en un lugar
increíble en un evento espectacular
bueno la alfombra roja ya fue inaugurada
no erika con la película annette
contanos qué sucedió cómo transcurrió
primero pensé bueno buenas tardes pensé
que las miradas eran para mí el santiago
no eran para él
está terminando justamente está
terminando justamente esa alfombra roja
del film annette una alfombra roja
tradicional la única diferencia es que
periodistas y camarógrafos tenían una
mascarilla obviamente negra además
porque desde las 5 de la tarde en todos
los eventos oficiales santiago se pide
una mascarilla negra para que obviamente
no desentonar con la elegancia de este
festival sino los artistas hicieron su
caminata estuvo carla bruni vela hadid
un montón de celebridades pedro
almodóvar que por cierto va a entregar
una palma de honor dentro de un rato a
judy foster la más francesa de las
actrices americanas y en este momento
está esa alfombra roja de annette el
filme que abre esta competición que como
tú decías tiene 24 películas una
película francesa de leos carax con
marion cotillard y el actor de moda de
hollywood and driver una tragedia
musical porque es una película muy
trágica que cuenta con la música del dúo
estadounidense
stark santiago se ha podido ver a
muchísimas personalidades erika por lo
que contás háblanos ahora un poco del
ambiente no teniendo en cuenta este
contexto de pandemia pasó un año como
decíamos previamente sin festival de
cannes
exactamente un año sin festival de carne
pero el ambiente es súper bueno santiago
porque porque resulta que el festival ha
sido aplazado normalmente se hace en
mayo pero ahora lo estamos haciendo en
julio en pleno verano por eso también
hace mucho calor y eso hace que haya
mucha gente que está de vacaciones aquí
en la costa azul recordemos que a raíz
justamente de la pandemia hay muchos
franceses que no han salido al
extranjero se han quedado en este país y
obviamente la costa azul es un destino
de preferencia así que el ambiente está
aunque obviamente hay menos prensa y
menos festivaleros como se le conoce al
público del festival hablando
precisamente bueno de ese ambiente no
condicionado por el contexto de la
pandemia haremos ahora muy vinculado a
esto que decía erika sobre las
restricciones no las medidas sanitarias
también para la prensa
para la prensa y para los festivaleros
en general al santiago para poder
asistir a las proyecciones de las
películas en competencia se te exige un
pasaporte sanitario de la unión europea
esto es tener tus dos vacunas al día y
haberse vacunado hace más de dos semanas
y no estás obligado a pasar un test se
ha puesto un laboratorio a los pies del
festival con test de saliva pero la
verdad es que no marcha muy rápido así
que uno también se puede ir a hacer un
test por su cuenta sólo así se puede
entrar al famoso palacio de festivales
donde ojo las mascarillas son
obligatorias pero te quiero presentar a
una invitada que tengo aquí de
cinemachile constanza del acompáñame
estamos en directo con france24
constanza arena muy bien muchas gracias
muchas gracias a ustedes ya forma parte
de las delegaciones de los países
latinoamericanos que participan del
mercado del festival que es algo muy
importante de este festival ella
pertenece como decíamos a chile y para
ellos también ha sido muy difícil llegar
hasta aquí no si justo te escuchaba
hablar de lo de los exámenes
efectivamente complejos salir del país
luego entrar al país y la sorpresa al
día 1 de mercado como es para
el día de hoy fue descubrir que para
entrar al palacio de festivales donde
uno se encuentra con la parte de
industria nuestro nuestro paseo de
vacunación que lo tenemos todos al día
no es válido sólo si es de la unión
europea así que me demore un poco por
los trámites del resultado ver etcétera
es un poco más engorroso de lo habitual
constancia igualmente pese a todos los
problemas para llegar para chile para
los países latinoamericanos en general
es importante estar aquí porque muy
importante el cob it nos ha obligado a
una especie de confinamiento industrial
de confinamiento profesional que genera
una baja de mano de obra de fuerza de
trabajo y de producción por lo tanto
realmente reactivar nuestra industria es
clave
khan es clave participar en mercados y
mantener los vínculos internacionales
muy vivos este año no hay ninguna
película latinoamericana en la
competencia oficial hay una colombiana
tailandesa hay muchas otras
hay dos mexicanas con producciones en
una cierta mirada que es
la sección alternativa dos segundos para
decir latinoamérica cómo está el cine
bueno nosotros estamos con dominga
sotomayor en el special screening en una
película colectiva así es que es nuestra
representante chilena y latinoamérica en
esta edición corta muchas gracias y
gracias santiago desde cannes saludos
para todos gracias sabores erika también
a constanza despedimos de esta manera
nuestra audiencia estaremos informándole
a lo largo de nuestra continuidad
informativa sobre este importantísimo
festival de cine de cannes sigan con
nosotros
[Música]